how's it going bros my name is supported
by I think you know my name by now nine
billion news today we're gonna check out
the top 10 weirdest ios games
japanese once i find some weird games
i've played them all before because I
recorded this [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] video and then record the gameplay
so we're just gonna do this again it'll
be fun
first game and probably my favorite out
of all 10 but we're gonna rank it number
10 anyway kauai mew mew leaked
you
oh sorry I just got a lost thing what
the [ __ ] I was doing it with my life
you're this cowboy cat who Wiggles the
head and it shoots on the walls and the
goal is to get as high as possible it's
very exciting very fun very nice
graphics
it's nice sound effects watch out for
crow couldn't hit will [ __ ] you up
don't worry I know it's slow now but it
will pick up the pace it's not right
come on cat
look there's fishes you get the fishes
and you just [ __ ] first up in the air
like you don't care look at 9 billion
News Knicks game is another cat game are
you surprised
well ma'am you can't write a fairy came
alone so here are basically cats and a
trolley and you like diamond diamonds
and you watch out for the water oh my
god the ghost can learn the kitties no
don't narrate Lyra was retired
number three now this is clear this is
this is my favorite out of all of them
I've said that before it well you don't
know me I still haven't figured out what
it's about
but I I think you make carrots
and that's all I got really I haven't
gotten further than this next game I
don't know what it is either I think
it's called chicken stick it's chicken
[ __ ] chicken stick [ __ ] [ __ ] stick uh
I'll look at rare one yes
Wow oh God oh boy the goal is to collect
as many chickens without making the
stick full and now if that doesn't sound
appealing to you then feel free to stop
watching this video goddamn rare chicken
oh god that stick is sure it's falling
soon where's Anna
whoever came up with this idea is genius
this is click the eyebrow chicken that's
that's a rare one I've been looking for
that one for a long time how you doing
there my chickens as thick is holding up
well
number five is probably my favorite out
of all of them I know I said that a lot
of times but this this is legit this is
legit and so you may think the game is
loading or some [ __ ] right now but know
this this is the game so you click on
this bold man who looks very collide and
you put them down on the OL four and
then you oh that's a big one
put the big one down he's a little
awkward I don't really know how to like
ah that's great I love when they make an
awkward noise - because that just adds
to the gameplay yes bold pajama man
mustache stacking I think the game is :
Japanese it's a direct translation like
this game all day this is why Japan is
the leading force in a tower building no
no my tower my boss meant let's see what
we got 18 that's that's pretty good mmm
I'm proud of that one oh really proud
the next game is my favorite the battle
cats Wow
I'm warning you brothers this game is
[ __ ] addicting as [ __ ] so when I was
playing we invaded oh my god I played it
so much Mongolia
Korea China Thailand Cambodia
Philippines
I'm sorry I know I have a lot of bros in
Philippines majeure you're going down so
this is our base and we can level it up
which gives us money faster and then
that's the Philippines they are a big
one big banana tree apparently and we
can send out a battle cat this is gonna
be a tough battle may the best cat team
win or snake
oh my god this is so intense
and as I said man buildin huge so next
game is called the legendary ever
blacksmith I don't know what the point
of this game is but I'm clicking
blacksmiths hammers thanks
am I having fun um sure oh I'm supposed
to hit them down here got it oh my god
bad ash I'm like a blacksmith just what
everyone wanted a blacksmith rhythm game
whoa pretty exciting gameplay I bet
you're having fun wow what the [ __ ] does
that mean that's a butter knife my
favorite game
next game is I played this and it gave
me nightmares
I don't want to go back and playing this
I still don't know what that [ __ ] it is
and that's why it's so scary I move in
this I click in this key thing moves and
then what I can do is I can upgrade I
can give it ears
Robert ears so now it's building grow
buddy it's for think I'm building like a
sex robot there we go we build ears
engage great she has ears now look at
that
I don't need I don't know i okay what's
next arms let's fill them all right she
has a he or she item I don't know
she has arms am right oh of course that
yeah she's a seal a robot seal oh my god
if anyone oh you bros wanna download
this game and see what happens
don't complain to me if satan connect
contacts you and ask for your legs I
don't know alright oh my god she fell
what the [ __ ] stop falling I'm sorry so
happy [ __ ] L alright you know what fine
fine fine
you might legs
what they're gonna look so pretty my
love she looks fabulous fabulous how's
it going everywhere I'm happy
look how much you can build on this
[ __ ] [ __ ] this is ridiculous
oh my god you know what I have enough
nightmares to think about all right
that's it okay next game is called a
billion wipes I play this fair fair deal
it's basically a cookie clicker and once
you get enough wipes you can see here I
have a prawn wife came on a wife to your
wife and our chihuaha this goes on I
need two point four four I don't know
what what wife that is but the goal is
to get to ten billion all right I think
we can afford a new wife yes
what do we get what do we get whatever
get what wife are we getting what am I
going oh my god
oh you married ODU wife I have so many
wives oh my god we almost finished a
[ __ ] game are you [ __ ] kidding me
I am such a [ __ ] loser okay I should
stop I think I have a problem
Jesus Christ
oh let's don't forget to check on our
carrot oh my god they all know they were
rock dad god yeah
alright so for the final game of today
is do you boys remember that alpha K
game well this is for the same traitor
fabulous family M favorite favorite
favorite babbitt family
so we're killing ourselves with our you
grown rank and then we suck each other
up suck it up suck it up suck it up suck
up suck them all up just suck it up be
fabulous we're gonna live it up now
you're gonna live it up here we go holy
[ __ ] brain molding
we evolved into a loading screen all
right well we had enough [ __ ]
nightmares and [ __ ] today let's look at
my carrots I'd be good huh
carrot yeah [ __ ] yeah carrots oh my god
what is that yeah
carrots so those were the top 10
weirdest iOS games which one did you
think was the weirdest let us know in
the comments I don't know us I guess
Edgar was yeah I want to know tell me
please they liked me enjoy watching hit
subscribe to come over today sorry if
this video stuck but I recorded it twice
oh [ __ ] me and I'll see you next one
stay awesome bros ah so nice I'm so glad
I can relive this if you for experience
inside a video game oh there's my sexy
body
alright I know you can Crouch in this
game so this there it is and there's a
poop